forty-two years after unbreakable
encryption tools were first conceived
that allowed individuals to communicate
in private they finally gone fully
mainstream
whatsapp has introduced a new level of
incredible fire OS five will offer hold
disk encryption encrypted privacy
protected disappearing one milestone
came in 2016 when the world's largest
messaging service announced it would
offer default end to end encryption on
all communications what messages can now
only be read by their intended
recipients and can't be accessed by
anyone else including governments or
whatsapp staff
law enforcement and intelligence
agencies are still reckoning with this
new reality for decades the demanded
tech companies hand over private data on
their users sometimes without obtaining
warrants so companies like Apple have
changed their policies making it so
individual users are the only ones with
the keys to their own data
sian his wife tashfeen malik opened fire
hours later they were in turn killed by
police this new era of consumer privacy
led to a standoff in 2016 when the FBI
demanded access to an encrypted iPhone
belonging to a terrorist from San
Bernardino California the FBI wanted
Apple to write software that would
weaken the iPhones built-in security
Apple refused telling authorities if the
company were to create such flawed
software that would work like a backdoor
it would create opportunities for
hackers to steal private information
what is at stake here is can the
government compel Apple to write
software that we believe would make
hundreds of millions of customers
vulnerable around the world it is in our
view the software equivalent of cancer
and yet there's plenty of consumer data
that's unencrypted and accessible by
large tech companies from Facebook to
Gmail law enforcement can still get a
warrant to get a hold of your data but
the growing use of end-to-end encryption
by Apple in particular represents a
drastic shift in power from government
to individuals but it's as if
unbreakable encryption popped up out of
nowhere
it's the privacy community's answer to
decades of government snooping year
after year technologists have battled
the government and the so called crypto
wars with the ultimate goal of giving
individuals total control over their own
privacy
chair recognizes senator from Delaware
in 1991 then-senator Joe Biden
introduced an anti-crime bill it
required that providers and
manufacturers of electronic
communications make it possible for the
government to obtain contents of voice
data and other communications when
authorized by law the best weapon
against terrorism is sound intelligence
knowing in advance what is likely to
occur having information essentially
requiring tech companies to provide
backdoors for government snooping
[Music]
programmer Phil Zimmerman decided to
build a tool that would thwart Biden's
efforts he wrote the first attempt at
encryption program for the everyday user
called pretty good privacy or PGP after
it was published online it spread
everywhere encryption is a way to
scramble your communications Cooper
Quentin is a security researcher and
technologist at the Electronic Frontier
Foundation if I send you a letter anyone
that sees the letter can read it and see
what it says but if I scramble it if I
replace each letter with a different
letter then nobody is going to be able
to know just by reading it what I send
to you an encryption is basically just
that but with a lot of fancy math that
makes it very very hard to unscramble we
need encryption because we need to be
able to tell secrets around the time
Zimmermann was working on his encryption
software America was getting its first
taste of the world wide web an online
network called Internet can you explain
what internet is the G is the online
service that connects your computer to
news shopping so America Online a new
way to use your computer and start to
see law enforcement getting nervous
because they can see the writing on the
wall that's Julian Sanchez he's a writer
and senior fellow at the Cato Institute
and focuses on national security and
surveillance they can see that
effectively widespread use of this
network is going to require widespread
use of encryption and so there were a
couple methods the government used to
try to limit the growing use of
encryption as cryptographic tools were
being developed within the country these
were effectively under the law treated
as a munitions as essentially weapons
being exported and so they were subject
to limitations on the strength of the
key the key is a string of numbers
letters and characters that unlocks
encrypted messages and the longer it is
the more complicated the mathematical
equation at its root which makes it
harder to break in 1993 the Justice
Department launched a criminal
investigation of Zimmermann on the
grounds that he violated the arms Export
Control Act the idea was that by
publishing a tool as powerful as PGP at
protecting encryption he was guilty of
exporting munitions
to demonstrate the PGP was protected by
the First Amendment
Zimmerman got MIT press to print out its
source code in a book and sell it abroad
Justice Department officials never
indicted Zimmerman and they began a long
process of coming to grips the legal and
technical challenges of regulating
software so challenging that they went
into the software business themselves at
the same time there was an attempt to
sir preempt stronger domestic encryption
technologies by offering their own
alternative and that's when the
government developed a proposal that was
known as the Clipper Chip the Clipper
Chip was an encryption tool developed by
the National Security Agency that had a
built-in way for the government to gain
access to the information it was the
first backdoor a backdoor is an
intentional flaw in a security system
that lets you and only you and gain
access to the system that you wouldn't
otherwise have the idea was to make the
Clipper Chip an industry standard by
taking advantage of the government's
purchasing power the privacy advocates
fought back this was really the first
crypto war the fight between law
enforcement and governments and a whole
lot of computer scientists and privacy
activists over whether the Clipper Chip
would become the standard for encrypted
telephone communications the Clipper
Chip represents a new approach to
encryption technology well I don't think
that there is anything scary about the
Clipper Chip proposal ID also expected
to be safe in the name of Zeus would
anybody outside the United States buy
one of these things if you've got that
insidious little spy in it it's a fight
it looked like the government might win
until a computer scientist named Matt
blaze discovered certain flaws in the
Clipper algorithm which everyone had
been sort of assured was was absolutely
airtight showing that you know first
that it would actually not be that
useful for the purpose law enforcement
intended but also that the government
was perhaps not as good as evaluating
whether encryption technologies worked
as advertised typically when you try to
invent your own cipher you end up
exposing your own information to
somebody who's just a little bit smarter
than you or somebody who has the access
to information that you just didn't
happen to know
an ever-present theme in the crypto Wars
is that the government is always a step
behind the privacy community in
developing encryption technologies just
the fact that the FBI thought Apple had
access to the data on the San Bernardino
terrorists iPhone is evidence of how out
of touch the agency often is after the
Clipper Chip episode law enforcement
agencies seemed resigned to the new era
of encrypted telecommunications there
was even a compromise of sorts between
telecommunications companies and law
enforcement called the communications
assistance for Law Enforcement Act
companies could still offer encryption
but they had to preserve the ability to
wiretap they would be under no
obligation to guarantee the ability to
decrypt that was for the trade-off so on
paper it looked like the crypto nerds
had won but in secret we now know that
the intelligence agencies were not lying
down and accepting defeat the NSA
specifically targets the communications
of every their capturing that the data
as it moves across the mail call grandma
in Nebraska the NSA knows the Snowden
revelations revealed spying but also how
the NSA was served tisha Slee targeting
encryption one of the ways was by
corrupting a widely used software
program called dual EC with malicious
code the program was used by many big
companies to generate the language that
made up the key that was used to unlock
encryption not a pure backdoor but they
had what's called a shortcut
but using the shortcut didn't last long
researchers who used to Alesi quickly
figured out the algorithm was
compromised the NSA went back to the
drawing board the problem for
intelligence agencies is that encryption
is math and so you can pretty much be
100% confident that you know how secure
something is the math tells you this
can't be broken and being a big
government with a lot of money to throw
at it doesn't change the math the answer
when you know you can't break the
encryption is break the end point the
end point turned out to be the hardware
people use to connect to the internet
the NSA is planting backdoor spyware and
american-made computer devices before
they are shipped overseas the result of
this was unsurprisingly a fair amount of
anger from the companies that are
responsible for making this stuff the
CEO of Cisco sent a pretty irate letter
to President Obama saying in effect I
can't do business under these conditions
and the head of Cisco wasn't the only
one the growing outrage over NSA
snooping began to grow in Silicon Valley
after the Snowden leaks they didn't
knock they didn't call they didn't send
a letter if you don't comply it's
treason you know so frankly III think
that the the government blew it
companies like Apple and Google reacted
to the NSA's actions by announcing they
would strengthen encryption in their
products
Azzam breakable encryption becomes more
widespread law enforcement still access
it back doors are a viable option
the FBI supports information security we
support strong encryption but
information security programs need to be
thoughtfully designed so they don't
undermine the lawful tools that we need
to keep this country safe it's sort of
too late to read bottle the genie what
would make more sense is to accept that
encryption is a good thing that makes us
all more secure and then building
vulnerabilities into it it's probably
gonna impose more security harms than
benefits it's gonna create for law
enforcement what's worse is that the
government may never realize how
important secrets are to every single
part of our lives telling secrets is
fundamental to modern society it's
fundamental to any sort of economy and
it's fundamental to democracy I need to
be able to tell you secrets I need to be
able to think secret thoughts so that I
can push the bounds of my society and
challenge it the government is losing
the latest battle in the crypto Wars but
there are new tools on the horizon like
quantum computing which could break many
standard encryption algorithms and shift
power back into the hands of the state
but history shows that while the fight
is never over technologists have managed
to remain one step ahead of the
government developing new tools and
strategies that protect individual
privacy from the overreaches of the
surveillance state
[Music]